um
[Music]
can't get to that door
hey there
i didn't hear you come in
best night ever let me know in your yeah
i will
i'm stuck
look
how he i don't it was christmas eve he
hit
how i
i look
oh god look
i didn't know
please
talk to me
so then
when your father i guess
how'd you
it was my mom
it was oh
hey
after
i
everything all them
yeah
but
things
what the cop
sure you only shot
just
i wanted to tell you
i just
so then
i can't take this
silence
why did i tell you
police open up i'm with the police turn
around please
what me yes you hands behind your back
let's go hold still
all right
now you hands behind your back please
help me don't move will you come help me
i don't know
this is a mystery
this is misunderstanding
[Music]
[Music]
hey there
hello hey
please he is what
listen i'm trapped
not now okay
hey
leave a message
um
here's it
i'm not thirsty anymore but thanks
i was not expecting a storm tonight
i'm stuck
look
how he i don't know it was christmas he
hit me
i couldn't
i
look
oh god look
i
please talk to me
so then
he's how you felt yes
trust okay
uh
i wanted to tell you
i just
i'm sorry
i know it doesn't matter but i am
will you just say something
anything
i can't take this
silence
god
i should never fool you
babe
excuse me ma'am sorry will you follow me
to your apartment please i'm with the
police wait
no
make a noise
i'll break your arm back inside
now
thank you
what's going on sure i have a warrant
right here
let's go hey listen
whoa whoa i didn't do anything sure you
didn't
i'll deal with you in a minute way more
complicated anyway
i know where the watch is this is way
more complicated than you think i i have
it here with me
just take it and leave us alone no no no
no
wait wait wait please please listen
there we are come on thank
you baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey there
i'm stuck in a
look
how he i don't it was christmasy he hit
i
i look on my side oh god look
i
please
talk to me
so
he's how you yes
trust me
okay
uh
i can't take this
silence
so
i don't forgive all the men
yeah
but
just
i should never have told you
babe
oh god
sure babe
babe
i can't open that with just my hands
sorry
will you follow me to your apartment
please i'm with the police wait
no
make a noise
thank you what's going on
i have a warrant right here
this will go easier if you cooperate
hold still
all right
now you hands behind
babe will you tell him
this is a misunderstanding
whoa whoa
look i
i'll deal with you
we can talk this out i [ __ ] warned
you
you're making a mistake this is
[Music]
wait wait
[Music]
gotta stop fighting that guy
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i'll be out in a second
okay
my
um
uh
oh god look
i didn't
please
talk to me
so then
he's how you found out about me yes
copped when you're i guess they were
close [ __ ] what do we do
trust me
okay
i don't care i forgave all the men
yeah
but you won't forget
things
wait what the cop
sure you only shot of course i think
hey
god
uh i i need to
just
i wanted to tell you
so then
i can't take this
silence
babe
hey babe
babe
and we're back
[Music]
[Music]
i'll be out in a second
i didn't hear you
not now okay
um
huh
what
oh yeah thanks i was about
hey i finally remember to put spare key
outside
so tired all of a sudden
oh
those pills are
i can't sure why the picture when she's
like this
she's out
now we wait
police open up
come on i know you're home open the door
he just passed out
oh
is this the watch you're looking for
[ __ ] off
what
oh oh you little [ __ ]
just made the biggest mistake your life
one chance let me go right now
is this the watch you're looking for
[ __ ] off
listen
i'm sorry i just found i don't have
all her so
listen
i can just work with
uh you know what
[ __ ]
whoa hey
what are you doing with that thing
but by new year's she was hunt
she's a murderer
you're a monster
you're a monster
look at this picture
look at this picture
what about it look at the date
december 31st
that's that's the day she murdered him
no no that is the day he was murdered
but she was hundreds of miles away
i don't understand
no [ __ ] it wasn't her she didn't kill
him
what do you know about the nanny who the
nanny the old man had the affair with
what do you know about her oh why do you
care about the nanny it was years ago
so
who could have killed her father i don't
know everything points to her
stop crying listen up
so
i don't know everything
stop crying listen up
your daughter don't you
cut me loose
so
i don't everything
come on
[ __ ]
that won't make any difference anymore
that won't make any difference anymore
that won't make any difference anymore
oh
[Music]
oh
i'll be out in a second
not
okay
i'm done with you have more questions
man can't get to that door all class
today
[Music]
we're back
i'll be out in a second
rude
i'm stuck
look
oh
it was christmas eve he hit you
i couldn't
i look
oh look
i didn't
please
talk to me
so then
you didn't kill him what when you shot
him he survived no that can't
babe he didn't die
and somebody else came in somebody but
it wasn't you you weren't there
okay you ready there's more a man is
about to ring the doorbell and what he
was closer than when your dad died
i need to sit down
your nanny
[Music]
i honestly i think i over
no way she
you know i have no sometimes my mom and
i i'm sure my dad would
so
i mean is that i mean
i never
now we wait
this
is that him
let's talk later is
is that him
would it be come on i know you're home
open the door
we need to tell him the truth
okay
police i have one for your arrest wait
wait wait wait wait wait please wait
stop i have something you need to see
what did you say
i didn't kill anyone look i can
no excuses
you have to listen to me
no
i do not
only people i have to listen to are my
daughter and my mother
and my mother's dead
now shut up
that's enough hold still
no i didn't do it
this is a mistake
babe will you tell me hey listen
this is she has a quiet
look
i don't know there's a piece of evidence
i need wait wait wait listen
babe show him the photo where's your
father's pocket watch i know you've got
it no look at the picture bait faith
give it to him it's important
it shows i'm innocent sorry
i never
hey listen
she has a problem
please listen
this is more complicated than
please just go
i won't
[Music]
all right it's getting easier
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey there
i didn't hear you come in
best night let me know yeah i will
hello hey hey
your dad says that my wife murdered her
father can you help please he is going
to hurt her what are you talking about
why would you say that
listen my wife is innocent but your
daddy he won't listen to us i don't know
what you're talking he doesn't have the
whole story please could you just tell
him to listen to us no why would please
he's just he's making a big mistake you
can help him i mean
fine
okay
i'll call him
i'm stuck
look how you're i know what are you know
what
it was and he hit you how
i
i but he didn't worry he survived
somebody
that'll improve this
i know
okay you ready there's more the man is
about to
what he was close to your father and
when your dad died
now we wait
hey bumblebee
what's up
what
what
honey i think you got prank calls
did they threaten you
listen to what
oh okay i'll listen to him but honey
yeah
don't worry bumblebee i'll take care of
this
i love you more
all right is that him
wait stop i have something you need to
see
what did you say
i didn't kill my father i have proof
there's a picture of me the day he died
i was hundreds of miles away show me
on the fridge please look
don't move
nope
no photo
that's enough
this picture
say another word we're gonna keep
hold still
[Music]
and we're back
[Music]
[Music]
hello hey
please
i don't know hey
he doesn't okay
but lose my
hey there
i'm stuck
look how
i know what are you know what it was
chris and he hit you how
i
i but he didn't worry he survived
somebody
that'll it proves you this i know
a man
he was close to him when you're dead
i need to sit down
this is too much
here's this
i'm not thirsty anymore
and some cop guy is coming
okay we'll
tell him the truth
the lesson right
[Music]
eight years i thought
i thought he was dead
if i'd known
no we wait i thought he was
hey bumblebee
what's up
what
what do you
honey
i think you got prank calls
okay i'll listen to him but honey
yeah
don't worry
i'll take care of this
i love you more
all right is that coming up
okay okay
oh [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait wait please please
i know wait stop i have something you
need to see what did you say
i didn't kill my father
i have proof
there's a picture of me the day he died
i was hundreds of miles away show me
on the fridge please look don't move
i'll be damned
listen
i know my father was important to you i
miss him too
but i
i always thought
you weren't there i wasn't there but
then i don't know
but it wasn't
me i'm sorry
i really am
my daughter she
she's all i care about she's dying
can't you
in the insurance form
i can't pay for the treatment
that watch though
it could cover it all
god if she knew i was doing this
thank you for not
if you told her
what i was really here for she'd never
talk to me again
i'm going now
wait just a second
here
take the watch
you need it more than i do
she does
i'm pretty good at finding people
obviously
i'll find out who killed your father
thank you
actually there's one thing that might
help
what when i found him he lost a lot of
blood i tried to stop the bleeding but
anyway he was saying something what was
he saying just the word monster over and
over i always wondered what it meant
it's my brother
oh my god
you have a brother
my mom was right
she was right all along when my father
and my nanny were having their affair
there was a baby
a boy a baby i knew about the affair but
he never mentioned a child my mother
hated him for it hated the kid too
always yelling at my dad about the
monster that's him
i didn't know i'm sorry
but
i'll find him
for you and for him thank you
wow
so what happens now
is it over
i think it is
yeah
now we can go find your brother and
move forward
yeah
yeah wow
i never thought i'd be able to tell
anyone what happened
i thought i'd have to hold that forever
but you listened
and you're still here i told you
i'm not going anywhere
man
i really really love you
really
really
i really love you
you too
i don't know
i just don't know
hey there
i didn't hear you come in
best night ever
let me know yeah i will
hello hey hey your dad says that my wife
murdered her father can you help please
he is
listen uh you did so that he can pay for
what
my wife has this expensive poc what are
you just call fine
i was not expecting a storm tonight
honey i think you've got prank called
honey that's impossible
of course it's not true
i wouldn't
hey you're my little girl
i'll do anything
okay i i
won't hurt anyone for you i promise i
double promise
yeah okay
i'll be right there
oh
uh
let's talk
[Music]
and we're back
[Music]
[Music]
hello hey hey
your dad says that my wife murdered her
father please he is gonna hurt her what
are you talking about
listen
what he wouldn't do my wife
what are you called fine
i didn't hear you
not now okay
hey i finally remember to put the spare
key outside
oh
thunder
i wasn't expecting a storm tonight
i am ready for your dessert you saw it
well give me
oh wow
thanks for setting everything up
hmm
let's talk later
so when is the dessert not just a
dessert
i have just open it
so
are you gonna open
[Music]
yeah
i'm pregnant
so
how you feeling
hey
you think you're kidding me you're
incredible
and it will be so
yeah
hey
hey
don't laugh do you wanna
absorb yeah let's do it you lead i'll
follow
hey bumblebee what's up
lady
it's been a while huh
i cannot remember the last time we
danced
you know it's not just the two of us
dancing now
we got a third little dancer
she's riding shotgun
so there it is
oh you know
i'm just
hopeful i guess
hopefully
do you not want a boy
no no boys are fine it's just
if she is a girl she might be like you
and a woll could use more people like
you
ma'am
you do know the right things to say
helps to have a muse like you
i forgot how nice this is
my dance partner you seem
different
what happened
god i
did not think i could love someone this
much
you know what happens when you talk like
that
follow me
hi honey
hello
just
can you hold me
yeah
always
i really love you you know i do know
um
[Music]
what
no
[Music]
no
what else do i oh
i did everything right i did everything
right
hey there
i didn't hear you not now okay
hello hey
please
oh
here
you opened it
what the hell that was supposed
ugh
i'm stuck
look how your father i know how he would
what do you do
it was and he hit you how could i
i did what
your brother
he killed i have a [ __ ] i have he's that
pull it proof
a man is about
he was close and wondered
okay
the cop
his daughter has came that's i can't
imagine
your half-brother i don't know
i don't even know okay i was two years i
mean the cop said he knew what maybe he
was
no we wait
this is crazy
hey bumblebee
let's talk later why do you
i didn't think i had any other family
i don't know anything about him
i don't even know what questions to ask
oh yes
that's
the secret
that's the skeleton
and now that you know it i mean
if you'll still have me
you can start fresh
clean all right
let's talk later
is
is that him what do we do okay okay
let's talk wait wait wait wait please
wait stop i have something you need to
see
what did you say
i did
didn't kill my father what he had a love
child
destroyed
that's your killer
you're expecting
me to believe that i don't care what you
believe
the bastard destroyed everything i loved
destroyed my mother
she called him the monster and he was
monster
what
oh it's just
that was the last thing i heard him say
it never occurred to me that it meant
that
listen
i know my father was important to you i
miss him too but i've
i always thought
you weren't there
i wasn't there
but then
i don't know
but it wasn't me
look i know why you're doing this
i get it you could possibly you can't
make us pay for what your daughter's
going through don't take it out on us
i'm sorry
really i am
god
if my daughter knew what i was doing
she wouldn't understand
she'd never forgive me i'm going now
wait just a second
here
take the watch
you need it more than i do
she does
i'll look for you brother i'll start
with the nanny go from there how much do
you remember about her
i
it's been a long time
do you remember her name uh something
flowery
daphne daisy something like that i'll
dig into it i'll let you know when i
know more
wow
so what happens now
is it over no
no it's gonna happen again
i have no [ __ ] idea what it
no oh no no
the nanny
um
[Music]
but he's actually
his daughter has
he was close
yeah i need to sit down
this is too much
and some cop guy is coming
okay hello hey
all these years
i thought
i mean
maybe he was
but you
i mean
hi nice
i didn't
i get
but well
let's talk
this is crazy
my brother
baby clothes with my mother she wants to
name her dolly
baby clothes
she wants to
i don't know anything about him
now we wait i don't know anything about
him
i don't even know what questions to ask
i guess
i mean
the good news
your nanny what do you remember about
her my danny
i was
i never i mean
maybe he was i guess
i mean
your nanny what do you remember about
her my danny
i was
i mean the cop said
maybe he was i guess
i mean
the good news
that's it
that's the secret
that's the skeleton
and now that you know it i mean
if you'll still have hey
don't move wait stop i have something
you need to see what did you say
i didn't kill my father
he had an affair stop talking please
will you just listen to me no i listen
to innocent people not murderers
honey i
please let me talk
no i listen to innocent people not
murderers
[Music]
[Music]
um hello hey
please
my wife i don't know hey
he doesn't okay
but lose my number
um
now
hmm
i didn't hear you come in
best night ever guess who made dessert
let me know when you're in the mood yeah
i will
oh
thunder
let's talk i wasn't expecting a storm
tonight
baby clothes she wants to name her
dahlia after my mother
baby
i'm stuck
look i know what do you know
he's gonna accuse you of him but he's
his daughter
he was close to your father
yeah
you have to i don't know
i don't even know okay
i mean
maybe he was there back
now we wait
no we wait
this is crazy
hey bumblebee
what's up my brother
what
nanny why do you what do you remember
about her
honey
i was
don't worry
i'll take care of it i don't know
anything about him
i love you more
i don't even know what questions to ask
i guess
i mean
all right
is that him
what do we do
do we open the door
come on we need to want to talk okay
wait wait wait wait
wait stop i have something you need to
see
what did you say
i didn't kill my father what he had a
love child
bastard
that's your killer
you expect me to believe that i don't
care what you believe
the bastard destroyed everything i loved
destroyed my mother she called him the
monster and he was
monster
what
oh
it's just
that was the last thing i heard him say
it never occurred to me that it meant
that
listen
i know my father was important to you i
miss him too but
i
i always thought
you weren't there i wasn't there but
then i don't know
but it wasn't me
look i know why you're doing this
i get it you could possibly you can't
make us pay for what your daughter's
going through don't take it out on us
i'm sorry
really i am
god
if my daughter knew what i was doing
she wouldn't understand
she'd never forgive me i'm going now
wait just a second
sir
look at this cute one
what
the name look at the name is that the
nanny oh the nanny from the old man's
affair
what oh
yes
dahlia that's it her name was dahlia why
are you saying this is some guy please
this is funny to you
she was my
mother
oh
no
no
[Music]
hey come on snap out of it
look i know this is a lot to drop on you
but i gotta know that we're on the same
page
concerning these feelings
so consider your answer to this question
very carefully
what do you want with my daughter
i can't just stop
feeling for her
i love her i love her with everything in
me
i don't care about your feelings feel
however you feel feelings don't matter
what are you going to do
you
you're [ __ ] radioactive you know that
just you exist i don't know my answer
yes i do
maybe i can just tell her the truth oh
you're just gonna tell her all this how
you think that's gonna go we're in love
we we'd overcome it you are so naive
such a child
it's the right thing to do no
this is
you [ __ ] idiot
you are so naive so stupid
oh
what the [ __ ]
okay you can't [ __ ] beat me
how could i forget honey babe are you no
no you stay back hey it's me it's me
it's okay it's okay
don't touch me let me help please stay
away talk to me
but
it can't be
true that can't be true
hey there
what are you doing no it wasn't it was
christmas eve he caught you sneaking out
and he hit you how could you know that i
couldn't
you told me in a previous loop i did
what
listen he didn't die when you shot him
what are you doing
he survived your brother that the one
you always called monster
i have i have he's the that pull it
proof
no
all right let's go he's coming for you
his daughter has in the water
he was close
yeah i need to sit down
i don't know how to forgotten a lot of
things that
what are you doing
i can't handle this why
oh no
[ __ ] i'm leaving
enough
[ __ ] enough
[Music]
and we're back
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello hey hey
your dad says that my wife murdered her
father can you help please he is going
to hurt her what are you talking about
why would you say that
listen
what are this lose my
[Music]
and we're back
[Music]
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] light switch
hello hey hey
your dad says that my wife murdered her
father can you help please he is going
to hurt her what are you talking about
why would you say that
my wife is innocent but your dad he
won't listen to us i don't know what you
want me hey please could you just call
him and tell him to listen
he doesn't have the whole story okay
fine
i'll call him but lose my number
i didn't hear you come in
best night ever guess who made dessert
let me know when you're in the mood yeah
i will
i'm stuck in a time loop and
look how your father died
it's not what you think i know how he
really died what are you doing it was a
heart attack no it wasn't it was
christmas eve he caught you sneaking out
and he hit you how could you know that i
couldn't
you told me in a previous loop i did
what
listen he didn't die when you shot him
what are you doing
he survived your brother that the one
you always called monster he killed him
a week later i have a [ __ ] brother a
half brother from your father he's the
one who did it that polaroid from the
coffee shop it proves what is going on i
know
all right there's more listen a man is
about to ring the doorbell he's gonna
accuse you of murder but he's actually
just here for your father's pocket watch
what his daughter has cancer in the
watch will pay for the treatment uh
what he was close to your father and
when your dad died it really
hit him hard yeah yeah
this is too much
and some cop guy is coming
there are things i need to tell you
things that if i could
you're an annie from your father what
about her name was though she was my
what your dad found it's
what are you saying it was you
oh my god i can't handle this why
it wasn't my it's not like you you're
like
[ __ ] i never want
enough
[ __ ] enough
babe
[Music]
will you follow me to your apartment
please i'm with the police
make a noise
i'll break your arm back inside
now
thank you what's going on i have a
warrant right here
this will go easier if you cooperate
wait stop i have something you need to
see what did you say
my husband just confessed
he's the killer
he's the monster
listen to me
why would i listen to you
you're a murderer
my husband
tell him your husband come on i'd listen
to someone
please let me talk
i'd listen to someone who doesn't wait
let me talk
i'd listen to someone who doesn't have a
vested interest in you being innocent
not your husband
that's enough
hold still
no it's not i'm not who you're looking
for i didn't do it
and we're back
i'll be out in a second
hey there
there are things i need to tell you
things that if i could go back
look i'm a mannequin what kind of look
his office is filled with books
what what
you've been blind
it's all my fault oh
god you're my only family if i could go
back go back
oh you're sorry
there's a cop coming here he's gonna try
and arrest you what how do you even
look i can't undo but i'll clear your
name who are just let me try to fix this
i ruined everything you're just fine
hello hey hey your dad says that my wife
murdered her father can you help please
here what
listen to me
this
your dad thanks i don't please look
please
huh
[Music]
hmm
okay
hey
we are
hey bumblebee
what's up
what
what
honey
i think
love you more
all right let's do this
you think you're funny calling my family
what what are you talking about
no more games hands behind your back now
wait stop i have something you need to
see
what did you say
i know you think i killed my father but
please just listen to what my husband
has to say
okay
do it
you have anything you want to tell me
what are you waiting for
well
okay so
listen
it was me
i'm the one that killed the old man what
the last words he was saying before he
died monster monster
i'm the monster
that's what his wife
what her mother called me
when she found out that i existed jesus
you killed your father and married your
sister
this is all on me
she didn't know it's not her fault i i
just told her like the truth a second
ago
i
i don't
uh we'll deal with that later there's a
watch i want
the watch
do you have it
we'll give you the watch we won't tell
anybody no one has to die okay hand it
over well i don't have it with me let me
just grab it yeah it'll just be ah nice
try it
no
no
[Music]
[ __ ] you
[Music]
i'll be out in a second
i didn't hear you come in
best night ever guess who made dessert
let me know when you're in the mood yeah
i will
there are things i need to tell you
things that if i could
look it was i'm a man of kill what kind
of look is
what
you've been up lying
it's all my fault baby you were if i
could go back
you're sorry
jesus
i wish
cops come in here you don't have to baby
i can't go but i can confess now i just
let me try and fix this please you
deserve a real life you're disgusting
fine
we wait
huh
hello hey
please
i'm the one who killed the old man not
my wife excuse me your dad he doesn't
have the whole story please could you
just call him and maybe ask him to
listen to me how would you even get this
number yeah you bet i'm calling my dad
uh
laughs
foreign
hey bumblebee
what's up
what
what
honey
i think
oh okay i'll listen to him but honey
yeah
don't worry
you more
all right
you think you're funny calling my family
what
what are you talking about
no more gangs hands behind your back
now wait stop i have something you need
to see
what did you say i know you think i
killed my father please
just listen to what my husband has to
say
okay
so
you have anything you want to tell me
okay so
listen
it was me
i'm the one that killed the old man what
the last words he was saying before he
died monster monster
i'm the monster
that's what his wife
what her mother called me
when she found out that i existed jesus
you killed your father and married your
sister
this is all on me
she didn't know not her fault i i just
told her like
the truth a second ago i
i don't
we'll deal with that later there's a
watch i want
the watch
do you have it
yeah
we'll give you the watch we won't tell
anybody no one has to die
here
i'm going to leave now remember if i
found you once i can find you again and
you don't want to see me again
what just happened
i need you to leave
get out of here
get the [ __ ] out you [ __ ] monster
you hear me
get out of my apartment
i never want to see you again
[Music]
[ __ ] i did everything right what else do
you want i did everything right
[Music]
[Music]
no we wait
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] light switch
foreign
thank you
hey
there he is
you're back
look
i know this is
a terrible shock but we need to be on
the same page
these feelings for my daughter
your sister
look
hi hmm looks interesting this isn't how
i wanted to tell you
you deserve
both of you deserve better
you know the thing i hate the most
worst thing in the world
disappointed my little girl
well that was the worst thing
and now a baby
you
with your little
love
i guess it was always gonna happen
nothing stays swallowed down forever
so
you're gonna make a call
if i could go back well
things would be different
but you can't just
try again that's not how life works
so you gotta make the choice
and you gotta make it now
say something
say something
fine
you're gonna force my hand fine
god damn you just won't listen
sir are you sir
oh
you